[Musique]
ce vendredi 5 octobre le département et
pôle emploi ont signé une convention de
coopération bilatérale 2018 2021 visant
une approche globale de l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi
la lutte contre la pauvreté l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle des personnes
les plus fragilisées constitue une
priorité partagée par pôle emploi et les
départements basse et la mise en place
entre le conseil départemental de la
réunion et pôle emploi réunion de ce que
l'on appelle l'accompagnement global
l'accompagnent au bas mot global
s'adresse à des bénéficiaires du rsa ou
des demandeurs d'emploi qui ont des
problématiques sociales essai permet à
ces demandeurs d'emploi d'être suivi par
un binôme un travailleur social du
conseil départemental et un conseiller
de l'emploi de pôle emploi et ceux
travaillant en binôme avec le demandeur
d'emploi permet d'avancer sur les
problématiques sociales problématiques
de logement problématiques de santé est
problématique de l'emploi c'est-à-dire
recherche d'une offre d'emploi
réalisation d'un cv mise en place d'une
formation grâce à sa paire mais
travailler sur les deux sujets en même
temps avec une plus grande chance
d'aller vers l'insertion professionnelle
quels objectifs de l'accompagnement
global et donc de trouver une solution
pour la personne ce protocole acte une
volonté commune de mettre en oeuvre des
méthodes d'action et de coordination qui
favorise une articulation optimale du
champ de l'emploi et du champ social
garante de la réussite de l'insertion
professionnelle durable des demandeurs
d'emploi le département va retravailler
avec ses partenaires dans tous les
domaines notamment dans la lutte contre
le chômage
quand vous voyez le taux de chômage
aussi élevé à la réunion
le département ne peut pas rester à
l'écart de ce grand mouvement qui est de
travailler avec le pôle emploi par
l'emploi dispose d'une capacité
d'intervention sur tout le territoire de
la réunion et nous département nous
avons en charge le social les
difficultés des familles comment voulez
vous qu'une famille s'en sortent
si cette famille ne trouvent pas de
travail et bien les deux sondes y est de
trouver un travail et vivre mieux sa vie
dans sa famille dans son foyer
tout ça c'est lié c'est pour ça que la
démarche globale permet au département
de m les travailleurs sociaux du
département
or lien avec les opérateurs de quoi
l'emploi et quand nous mettons nos
forces ensemble nous sommes nous allons
plus loin nous avons plus d'efficacité
en 2018 mise en oeuvre progressive du
dispositif sera effectuée afin de cerner
au mieux les attentes des publics cibles
et de préciser les plus values de cette
démarche d'insertion
socioprofessionnelle
[Musique]